anyone here in Aztec death whistle sure
oh my yeah yeah I think you got a cop
it's uh Chitwood the Aztecs when they
were taunting the enemy they would do
that on the hillside like while they
were camped out and sleeping they would
keep them up all night
psychologically [ __ ] with them Jesus
Christ I'm blowing that death whistle no
deaths coming he's already an expert I'm
gonna do it for us
you think those some Indians like dude
maybe that's not a good idea let's sneak
up on them no Manthey is this games
sounds like a demon tell Stassi titties
oh [ __ ] dude now imagine a thousand
half-naked warriors that are definitely
gonna kill you and they're screaming now
from the whole side hopefully you love
titties like that guy this is badly I
know we're the Warriors okay you gonna
conjure a demon this is gonna blow out
your [ __ ] this is like one of those
you know it's a bad idea
evil Devils Gary man right Jesus dude
don't tell me that I had no energy
coming here and now I get here and I
have so much I know they keep saying
this is called bro energies weak energy
as we get older we cherish this the fun
times are like the best times everything
else is on Suns